how did you first hear that bill cosby
was going to be released
oh this morning when i got up and rolled
out of bed
my friend stephen lenahan he gave me a
telephone call
and he told me he said i have some bad
news
and i was bracing for like you know a
hurricane or something and he was like
you know cosby's out of prison and i was
so i felt i felt like
first of all really so angry
so angry uh
and second i felt like i was kicked in
the stomach by
in in my abdomen by some psychic blow
you say you felt like you were kicked in
your stomach but
you know they're saying this is a
procedural issue
and that's why he was released how do
you feel about that
i'm angry i'm angry they let him out
over a procedural that's that's
basically all i have to say i can't get
into the legalese of about it i can only
speak for my heart
and say that the statute of limitations
is not fair
it's not it's it's it's just not fair
there are people who are falling on both
sides but some people are rejoicing and
saying
he deserve you know it's it's only fair
that he gets out what do you say to
those people
oh i say to those people you have not
been raped by them
i i was raped by bill cosby and i know
that it changed my life forever
and that's why my heart goes out to all
the women
that started me too after i first came
out on the on your show
i i just think people are ignorant there
were so many facts
you know i mean i had polaroids of the
guy in a bathrobe
how does that still affect you well
today i have to admit i was
forlorn i was down just not
normally i'm talking up a storm to my
husband rocky this rocky that
i i couldn't even i basically didn't
want to look in the mirror
it was it's just a very
unjust verdict
what would you say to the other women
who clearly are going through things
tonight also what would you say to the
other women
i would say sisters we still have to
fight this
we have to fight any injustice that's
bestowed upon
a young girl or a young boy
we have to get together to change these
rules and the laws
of the statute of limitation if there
weren't the statute of limitation
he'd be he'd be in jail right now for
much longer than
two and a half years there was mounting
evidence from
many many women but once again they go
back and say
it has nothing to do with the crime it
has to do with the procedure
and what does that say to you about the
justice system
i think the justice system is really
i'm sorry for being so rude but it's
just to me it's like
devastating that the
after all the pain and anguish that
these women went through
myself included beverly johnson i know
they're feeling the same way i am
i know they're mad i know i know they're
disappointed
and uh sisters we got to hang in there
that's what i want to say to them
have you had a chance to talk to anyone
else oh yes
beverly johnson my friend you talked
today uh
yes oh and what was that conversation it
was
it was private it was private
but she wouldn't like me saying
what our conversation was about i don't
have her permission
but she's a great woman and she she too
had to fight him off
and she got away she got away unscathed
but she she's still mad as hell
mm-hmm if i remember correctly you guys
were in tahoe when this happened correct
yes you still remember that 1982 rino
nevada
you still remember it vividly i i
remember
the way the curtains were blowing inside
this room
i remember being extremely knocked out
by this pill he gave me
and dizzy and lightheaded and airheaded
i couldn't basically get up out of bed
and normally i think i can control
myself and i've i've always got like the
upper hand
as far as sobriety
i wish that i was sober as i am today
and that i wasn't that i was still
drinking alcohol
back in the day what we saw today was
justice
you think back to that time and then as
you saw that man
walking on his lawn today what went
through your head
if you could say something to him what
would you say oh
i would say don't be so happy with
yourself buddy because you know what you
did to me
let me show you something so we want to
thank this entire team we want to thank
mrs cosby your family
did you have a chance to see any of this
i watched it i watched the news all day
today
bill cosby didn't speak for himself he
didn't speak out loud
how his experience was he didn't
apologize once again to all the victims
uh where is his wife uh
you know who are these hangar hangers
honors around him
i would just i would say to him
personally
you've got a whole lot of nerve coming
out and smiling
and giving peace signs
what do you hope he says i'm sorry i i
would hope that mr cosby would say i'm
sorry
but that's never going to happen he's a
psychopath he never reached out to you
no never no did you get a lot of
pushback after you first came out
were there people who didn't believe you
or wanted to be on his side oh the
pushback
that that came out after after i was
like one of the first women that came
out
was uh negative negative negative i
had people calling me all sorts of names
and
uh called me liar
the attorney even called me a liar marty
singer
yeah he did what do you think of that
well
i won my court case
felicia rashad tweeted earlier today
that justice
had finally been served that's his wife
from the cosby show
um what's your response to that well i
really admire and respect felicia rashad
but today she needed she had backwards
thinking because
after she came out and said that she
then came out and said i support the
women
do you think she believes that he did
the things that he did
without a doubt she knew this guy was
off because
you can't work next to someone and not
hear the stories
or hear her hear the cadence in his
voice when women walk by
you know there were some people that
suggested now that this could open the
door and there was concern at first that
this could open the door for harvey
weinstein
what do you think of all that kind of
talk i think this is tragic talk
it's tragic it's tragic that they they
could actually
think that he could get out and i think
if harvey weinstein had the same uh
mistake happened with his uh accusations
that he would he would be walking the
streets i would say i would have to move
to another country
at this point it makes you want to leave
the country what's happening
well i never leave my children but
yes it just makes me really disgusted
with the system did he ever say anything
to you about what might have happened no
i want to ask you when you were here and
you first began to speak about
the cosby situation it was very
emotional for you
how long did it take before you could
really deal with
the trauma that came back up associated
with this rape
i'm still dealing with the trauma that's
come up
but after after the trauma did come up
the very first time i was not a pleasant
woman to live with ask my husband
you know i would have these mood swings
that i'd go in and out of like
just like being a spaz it always took me
back
to that fateful night in 1982 in reno
nevada
i just don't have any words to describe
the pain that's inflicted upon me
take me back to the time when andrea
constand first came
out and she was actually fighting her
legal fight against cosby and what you
remember and how it inspired you
i remember when it first came out in the
in the new york times article
andrea constand's case and
my husband looked at me and he knew he
knew that i was going to
do something about it you know we both
said it's time to talk
it's time now to come back out and say
something and
may the truth reveal itself how hard was
that for your husband to also know this
and know the hurt that this man
inflicted on you
uh you know i was i was crazy back in
those days
i was really my mood swings would go up
and down off the chart
you know be laughing one minute and then
i'd be just really angry the next
i was having a hard time with it kevin
it's hard when
your your spouse or your wife is going
through the
this because it leaves him powerless
there's nothing he can do
except hold my hand which he has done
how are you today
today i am sober through the grace of
god
i have a good great family a wonderful
husband two great children
two great step children a grandson i'm
very happy with my family
i never thought i'd be granny janney so
i'm fortunate and very blessed